i'm gonna play a little bit of a game
with you guys we're calling it freaky
questions with the cast of freaky
if you could swap bodies with anyone on
a film set and learn more about their
job who would you pick and why
so many interesting jobs on a set i'd
love to be the dp though
and just look through the camera the
whole time i think lighting is just the
coolest thing you could
the same oh my god 100 lighting for me
too
i couldn't agree more they can make you
look great they can make you look awful
and also like they set the mood
so lighting for me mine would be craft
services
just to be privy to the snacks and
maybe have a secret stash of some
nice tasty things that i could kind of
have and they got a lot of currency on
the set you know crafty
crafty will has the goodies and you want
to be in good good standing with craft
service
what is the weirdest thing you've ever
had to learn to do for a role
so i can't whistle and for those that
might want to hire me for whistling down
the line i'm shooting myself in the foot
but i was up for a roll and the roll he
this guy had to whistle
so i fully like pretended to whistle and
then
had a friend adr whistling over my
audition
the weirdest thing i ever had to learn
was probably on this movie freaky i
had to learn how to use a chainsaw it
was super intimidating and that thing
was real
it was a real chainsaw and i had to do
they had i had rehearsals just learning
how to do that a couple times and it was
cold so it was like
really like sticking you know so
i had to learn quickly let's just say
that i didn't get it in case we're all
curious
it's the fun of the job sometimes it's
like dancing or
you know driving combine or just
different unique things that you
normally wouldn't be exposed to i
i kind of enjoy that side of it it gives
you a chance to be exposed to stuff and
i think you get a greater appreciation
for things than doing that
i haven't really had to learn anything
crazy i had to learn how to roller skate
for one which is just really fun
so what are you freakishly
bad at apparently i'm freakishly bad at
cleaning up my room
i'm making my bed so it's my mom
you know i can be thinking about things
and sometimes
absent-minded with putting something
away so sometimes i feel like if i have
a lot on my mind
i can like uh you know
not really be paying attention to
putting things back so i can be
freakishly back
at that it's not a not a fun my wife
doesn't enjoy that quality
i also can't whistle either if that
counts
would you rather fight 10 catherine
newton-sized
vince vaughns or one vince vaughn sized
cafernoon
i want one target i don't care how big
they are because i want to see exactly
who i'm fighting and know
all the different angles if there's 10
of them in one of me i mean i'll still
win because i'm an incredibly confident
human
but like i don't i want one target
i think it would be kind of funny to see
like 10
uh catherine sized vince's
catherine's like not that short though
so i think that would be like
a like pretty hard uh opponent
what is the first movie you remember
seeing that really freaked you out as a
kid
oh well i feel like the first like
horror film i saw in theaters
was uh jennifer's body and i was so
scared and it's not even that scary of a
movie
i was just so freaked out but that one i
remember
that one scared me really bad her jaws
really scared me i saw that in the movie
theater
i remember i used to be nervous just
getting in the in the pool the
participle i was afraid
no way that was so kind of scary i
didn't understand the concept between i
grew up in the midwest so there was no
ocean so i didn't really understand the
concept at that age that
you know it took salt water it just felt
like there was potentially a dangerous
shark lurking in the
depths of the deep end of the buffalo
grove park district
what's the scariest face you can make
right now
[Music]
that was it can you like see my
breakfast don't wait no i don't want to
[Music]
say